What happens when all people
get together in a group.
You know,
we talked about that last time when we
talked about Kierkegaard idea that as
soon as you get a bunch
of people together,
no matter how truthful they are,
all as individuals,
instantly the crowd is
not a truthful thing.
And you know,
there,
there are,
there are real reasons for that.
Real psychological reasons.
So there's the famous ash experiments,
I hope that those are
the right experiments.
A S C h about Lyme lakes,
you know,
so you draw two lines on the board and
they're the same length and you get the
crowd to,
you know,
collaborate with you and you ask some
poor sucker who doesn't know about the
game,
uh,
to play.
And you know,
you ask one person and they say no,
those lines are different in length.
And you ask another person,
they say,
well,
yeah,
they're quite different in length.
Then another person says,
yeah,
this sure I can see the
difference in length.
And then you ask the poor pigeon,
you know,
are they different in length?
And he says,
yes.
You know,
and you can understand why.
It's like if all those
other people are saying it,
there's either,
there's either something
wrong with all of them,
which seems unlikely,
or he's the victim of a conspiracy,
which is a little on the paranoid side,
but happens to actually
be true in this case.
Um,
or he's just not looking at it.
Right.
And you might think,
well,
the humble thing to thank is he's wrong.
And so,
you know,
the fact that somebody might
go along with the crowd,
you know,
you can,
you can blame that on their,
on their ability to be
social and conventional,
which in many ways is a huge advantage
because if you are all antisocial and
unconventional,
you know,
I mean,
there'd be a good chunk of you in jail
and we certainly wouldn't be having this,
you know,
delightful,
peaceful conversation that we're having.
So,
you know,
you don't want to
underestimate the utility of
conventionality to too much of a
degree.
Anyway,
so
there's this funny story I read once.
I don't think it's true,
but it might be.
Whereas psychology class got together
and decided they'd play a trick on the
professor.
And the trick was that he
would walk back and forth,
Hey,
and,
and the trick was that they wouldn't pay
any attention to them at all if he was
on the left side of the room.
You know,
they talk a bit and look,
look up.
And if he was on the
right side of the room,
then they'd really focus
in and pay attention.
And the story goes that by the,
you know,
by several weeks of this little trick,
they had them like lecturing
right beside the door,
you know,
and he wouldn't move from that spot.
And so the reason I'm telling you that
is because it's pretty obvious that
people can respond to the cues
that a crowd is delivering.
You know,
when a good speaker does that,
right?
So a good speaker does a variety of
things and one is the never talks to the,
to the crowd per se.
You know,
when you pick out specific individuals
and talk to them and they're sort of
reflective of the crowd,
and then you can tell if
everybody's understanding.
And,
uh,
the other thing that a good speaker does
is pay attention to the damn responses
of the crowd.
Because you know,
if,
if a lecture is really a dialogue,
even though the audience
is only emitting nonverbal,
the nonverbal elements
of the conversation,
those nonverbal elements,
those damn things are important.
So you want to stay in touch
with the nonverbal communication.